it is
on page 521
it's about the line from the bottom
oh yeah
i'm just sorry i'm just picking this up
now there's no change the recommendation
isn't it
okay sir is there any sorry counselor if
you're okay with that
i just would like to know where this is
funded from when you said it's a
district regeneration
budget that comes now from green space
not on to the earthquake loan is that
correct
uh so the the car and boat trailer
parking at the coast guard
is a regeneration project funded from
the earthquake recovery loan
the ashkeeton boat ramp upgrade
is a green space activity budget
last year we actually stated that at
some point we have to stop putting extra
money in on the earthquake recovery loan
and get back to business
as usual if you need to actually
increase this budget
why wouldn't it be done through the
recreation budgets rather than adding to
the earthquake line
i think it wasn't though i think what
you're saying is it was always intended
to be in the regeneration it was it's
it's always been signaled as a
regeneration project
to be funded under the earthquake
recovery loan the reality is if we
shift it from that and put it in the
green scripts green space budget and
fund it through the green space
um the same rate payers across the same
district will
have the same rating effect
so my understanding of ish keaton in
going back to that
from early days was that that was going
to be abandoned
has that position changed
i don't think the community boards made
a decision on that
at this stage um so that's why they
elected for the
interim fix in the meantime um
to allow time and it's noted in the
report there's a proposal to do a
um a river use plan
just to consider this matter alongside
other matters and that that includes
consideration around what may happen in
some of the mixed use business
areas nearer to the town centre as well
in case that has an effect on some of
those decisions around
access to the river and
okay any further questions so you're
prepared to move
those so second that was the changes of
the indication and the rig
you're clear on those adrian the the
the yes with those changes yep just
checking
counseling yeah i understand a little
bit of the confusion around this it's
always
the the boat pack's actually always been
in the in the loan
um you sort of extend it out a little
bit more and it is a little different
um just just for some clarity um
certainly around the
community board and discussions we've
had with duncan and
and the team around this um if you drove
if you drove up uh
jones street no jones street yeah no
jones street
i think it is that comes out at the back
of the coast guard
there's a sign there that says boat ramp
pointing towards ashketer
interestingly enough if you go over the
bank there's a boat ramp
so anybody who's new looking for the
boat ramp will automatically
drive to ash keaton and try and launch
in that diabolical miss down there
while missing the point of the of the
coast guard ramp
so it's a bit of an anomaly in in the
way that we've
done things there but it's all if you
get it for the right purpose you know
it's just the way it has worked if you
come down um charles street well then no
problem you probably pick off the first
boat ramp which is the uh
which is the coast guard we have noticed
we did put
um a placeholder in everybody's mind in
the original stages that we would give
cash keaton
a couple of three years and see if that
started to dwindle
while the other one took off a bit and
unfortunately in the couple of three
years
not much has happened to actually change
everything it's almost a business as
usual
type situation however we've noted that
there are
more people using the coast guard ramp
now than there is
the locals are the ones that use the ash
keaton and for the reason they don't
want to
travel another kilometer at five knots
to get to where they're going just to go
fishing and i absolutely
get that argument the other thing and
complicating factor that
needs that we need to actually include
this for is the fact that
as you will have read by your emails
yesterday the motorhome association
has is going to take up a deal on the
space down there a lot of those people
tow boats it will be very interesting to
see whether they launch it the coast
guard
or whether they prefer the ash keaton
which means that we do have to sink some
money in there i actually
just to reiterate what i saw and told
the community board one day there was an
older gentleman who
was clearly new to launching his boat at
our district
and um when he got back to pick up his
boat he opened the door in the
of his car and the water poured out
because so that actually shows you the
uh how low ash keaton is and and
arguably is still
sinking so spending a lot of money on it
is in my view not a great idea but the
the plan that duncan's talking about
will um will help us
hopefully identify whether we do need it
or not
number two is this somewhere else and we
did try and investigate that when we
put the regeneration plan into place and
there really wasn't
any other spots to uh to put a
boat rim so all of that's a bit of a
complication so
we've sort of got to hang on for another
couple of three years and hopefully the
000 will do that and see if what we've
planned in the last couple three years
actually comes to some fruition because
if they start using the coast guard
dying off down the other end will then
the decision is made easy
if that doesn't happen and the reverse
happens then we've got a bit of a
bit of an issue coming but the fact you
can't park your boat and things there
and the reality is that increasing that
budget
there is no question on a saturday
morning in time to come
when the sports fields are used and
there's a
market on in the middle of guyboy and
all of those things
and you want to park your boat um maybe
come in that area
a little difficult but it's about sort
of placeholders for monitoring purposes
really and i stand to be corrected if
someone's if i've read that role and
people say that differently
councilworking
any further speakers council meetings
just having used that boat ramp recently
and and been
[Music]
kayaking up the river a bit recently
last weekend when we went up we put in
at ash keaton
and they were probably about 12
different
boats and and vehicles down at ash
keaton there was one at the coast guard
and i mean and that's not withstanding
the fact that
i basically launched my kayak from the
parking lot
because there was enough water to do so
and whenever we got back we picked it up
and carried it across a lot of mud back
up to the car
so um i can actually see
at the moment you know until people
catch on um
maybe you know having that placeholder
and making that usable
and also you know as we do develop
further you know
down there with the other facilities
we've got down that end of the
regeneration area
um it makes sense to to leave that
available
and for the other reason that a lot of
those those boats that were down there
were
just like my colleague here said where
people that didn't want to
have to navigate the extra kilometer or
so down the road
um down down the river to to the mouth
whenever they went fishing
i don't see any problem with passing
this the way
that it is written here and i'll support
it
counselor about it and you wish to speak
with one question
you can ask a question first
i just just want to clarify please that
with this at the moment is if you want
to do more development with it will that
be on the earthquake loan funding or or
what it's a question to start yes sorry
are you are you asking where if if in
the future we want to do more
development it is keaton
would that be on the earthquake um no
the the development that we're doing at
the moment
um at a skating the sixty one thousand
dollars is currently in the
um green space budget not um right okay
i just want to clarify that that's yes
so so if we wanted to do more or less
keaton in the future then it would be
likely that would have
been um going to the recreation account
as opposed to the recovery account yeah
that's good i just need clarification
yes um my questions i'm i'm totally
happy totally supportive of people using
the kaifu river i love the carpool river
and i think everyone should be using it
as much as possible
but the truth is people use what's
available so if we shut down each
keeping tomorrow they would go and use
the coast guard because it's available
um so you you go we you go with heaven
that's just normal and i totally get
that um and it has been a really good
area but i still remember craigslist and
talking about trying to put gravel in
and how it just disappeared
and the more we dumped down there the
more it just disappeared and disappeared
and we can't we really back then it was
like we couldn't fix it
and so therefore it was decided it would
have to be abandoned and this was
way back when before your time in that
space in this
regeneration um so
i i don't know what the future is and
we'll have to look at that maybe it's a
lagoon
for the kayaks um and um or maybe it's
something completely different
i mean i don't know but i i'm concerned
about sinking a lot of money into an
area that is sinking all right um today
we're talking budgets
and so that's why i wanted to question
this um i've made the point over the
last couple of years is
i think the earthquake line needs to be
almost closed we set a budget
and from now on we need to start saying
okay this is now
where we passed the stage we've got to
get to the point
where the whole district knows what
they're paying for as an overall
district
rather than looking at just regeneration
in this area
we we see this we set some budgets we
did some we did some changes we've added
some more
but it's not an endless fund so that's
why i was concerned about
increasing this budget under the
youthquake loan
and i know that this comes out the same
budget it comes out the same pocket if
you put it in green space
but it's the principle to me is that we
are now in a new stage in a new decade
and we need to move forward so i just
want to be very cautious
about any projects i mean this is 23 24
year that means we're still paying out
regeneration money out of that loan in
the 23 24 year
when effectively we should be trying to
pay it off and then look at our
development as a district and what's
good for the district
and having boat launching facilities is
really good for the district
um so that that's my only question is
where it says
and i want to make that completely clear
because we have been saying that for a
couple of years
that i'm not go i'm certainly happy to
include it
um but i do want to make the point that
we've just got to stop topping up that
budget
thank you mr mayor um i'm actually
supportive of
ask keaton since 1981 or two i've been
trying to have a jetty
uh in the river there to facilitate uh
launching and retrieval the earthquake
was an unfortunate event
and it has posed challenges for ash
keaton but councillor mealing's
observation 12-1
mirrors my impression people don't like
launching at the
uh coast guard boat ramp because it's
not user friendly to launch
uh the vision going over the bank and
have got a back and maneuver and so on
it's a nightmare i have also mentioned
in the past
about having a different system there so
you drive
past the coast guard and exit on the
other side of the building
and maybe if that happened it would
become more popular
so it'd be interesting to see whether
the car park there
will generate more launching at the
coast guard
so i'm happy to go along with this but
in the long term unless things
change um i still think actually keaton
has a role for launching certainly very
popular in my view
you're the speakers
well
yes the the earthquake loan i i'm i'm
not going to disagree with the council
about it we need to
uh we need to wind that loan up i get
that this is part that's been in there
the whole time and i mean
it just reflects the true costs of
a project that's always been indicated
it's not a new project
it isn't it is a project that's there so
if we were starting new projects i would
be
exactly of that opinion that we need to
to do it in another way so i don't i i
don't take comrades with that at all
um interesting um uh
councillor ridman's take on the coast
guard boat ramp i've said it many
ramps in fact i encourage you if you
ever in havelock to go to the restaurant
and have lock at the
restaurant is actually right on the boat
ramp and there's an afternoon's
entertainment just watching people
trying to uh trying to back into the
river but interestingly most people
back and when they make a mistake they
go at right angles if you do that the
coast guard you actually end up in the
water so
um it actually helps you rather than
hinge you
i don't disagree with the uh with the
in and out of coast guard and that has
actually been on the plan since day one
uh the plan that's been put in front of
us every time shows that
you go in there and then you
take a right-hand turn and you go out
over the top of the stop bank and into
the
into the park that was uh that was um
coast guard had something to say about
that because you were crossing crossing
their emergency doors
um in reality i'm not quite sure that
that's a
that's quite quite exactly how it should
work because i think you find that once
to
sirens go off no matter where people get
out of the way pretty damn quick
um so i think that more of a a thought
than a reality
but the reality with ash keaton is that
people do use ashketon for exactly the
reasons you're talking about
is habit one two ease i
get that because that's what they've
always done and number three because we
have a damn
sign that says that's where the boat
ramp is right in front of where the
other boat ramp is
so it just i mean that doesn't make
logical sense that that's there
but i get why it is there because you
want people launching their boats
um you know and making sure that they do
it safely quickly and
and get out of the way the first time
i've heard about uh council redmond
wanting to put a duty at uh
at uh uh s keaton i think i've been on
the
board for 20 something years and i've
been here for 19 years first time i've
actually officially heard that that's
happened i've never seen an official
approach yet
for that right okay okay but um
we just move on but what i'm saying is
that both of these things
that we just need a bit of time to just
get the real truth about where things
are falling and what they're doing and
we can do some really simple things to
make sure that we've got their truth
thank you i'll put the recommendation
all those in favor aye contrary to clear
that carried
okay so we've got two budget items for
you duncan
that you're responsible for so your
budget pages 504
anything you want to highlight in those
particularly
where they've read these so i think
you've got you wish to highlight
i'll keep it very brief but really just
to summarize starting with the
earthquake recovery
budget so from 504 onwards um
it's similar with the regeneration one
as well generally these are all existing
projects um that we've just put up again
from a point of view from the earthquake
recovery
program as opposed to regeneration
the recreation component that's uh
almost come to an end there's a couple
of
uh final projects to finish in the
coyote river air which is really the
rowing precinct in murphy park which
have been
uh had to be pushed out again related to
decisions around kaikou croquet
it's probably more dominated now by the
balance of the town centers projects
that understand you
considered yesterday morning
and there is one stormwater project left
in there which is now actually
it's tied up with or related to the
shovel ready program of works to do with
the feldwick train so
um other as i say no significant changes
um
there's a couple of new items that were
added
um to the budget uh page
uh 513 just the last couple of lines
there
one related to the non-slip treatment
for the riverview terraces
and there was another item there for
some final decommissioning of the
dewatering ponds on corcoran reserve
that we use for the dredging
thanks duncan that's the earthquake
recovery
questions on earthquake recovery
thank you duncan okay district regen
page 514. yeah similar story again no
um real changes there there were a
couple of projects that have actually
just been pushed out
um a year or split over two years now
and just note that there was one
new project added which was the cycle
training track which is out in
year 10 of the long term plan
any questions
um what does that mean i know what the
eco-linkage means
what's cara got to do with that sorry uh
yeah akira in this sense is kaiapoi east
regeneration area
it's not the residents association
association
gotcha yeah that's punched our acronym
any fifth questions catherine concerned
i'd won six car parking
car caravan trailer park 153k is that
the right figure
it's just because it's noting it as a
carryover so that's the existing budget
that's carried forward
okay any further questions
thank you duncan thanks for all your
work in this area appreciate it
all right uh we're going to move to the
regulation oh sorry what with
that next we've got chris couldn't
overhead anywhere
no yeah yeah um
no it's all done we've done that yeah
that's right i was just double checking
dismissed thanks chris
um right so we're now up to um
planning and regulation management i'm
looking forward to hearing what tracy's
got to say today
right okay
thank you thanks chris thank you
we are i really
got the finishing line in sight
and with that we've got our
planning and regulation budget to work
through and
it'll be a team tag team effort between
us all as to uh trying to present and
answer the budgets
i think the quick overview is that most
of them
have a have a strong status quo feel to
them
there's a couple of things on civil
defense and chris thanks for coming
along today when we get there
you can come and help uh answer any of
the tricky questions that might come but
um we've got a good handle on that as
well so there's
you'll be pleased to know and put
diligent away so diligent is done
for the day other than if you want to
look at the
resource center for v so we're we're
just now
in our sheets
and the first budget to look at is
on it starts for page 522 which is the
planning regulation management overhead
budget
this was prepared by nick before his
departure
of retirement and
absolutely a status quo budget it
provides for
that manager role and the other
significant item in there
is legal fees which invariably we need
to spend dealing with the tricky issues
we get from time to time but it's pretty
much
a status quo budget which is reflected
on page 5 26 happy to take any questions
any questions
any quick any questions for tracy
no all right moving forward
thank you okay so that gets us to plan
implementation here and
happy to hear your introduction thanks
jim so
um very much similar to the manager
budget in the sense that it's a very
much a status quo budget
can you speak very much a status quo
budget
uh reflecting um that we've just had
sort of steady growth of resource
consent numbers
uh over the last few years and that's
that's certainly continuing
towards the start of this year um i do
make note of
the upcoming rma reforms which haven't
been factored into the later years of
the budget but they will certainly
uh create some changes that we'll need
to work through
in addition to that as well that the
district plan review
and just working through the consenting
regime for that
probably the only other point to point
out
is there's some slight changes to fees
and charges
um categories and for the most part they
either
go go down or or sort of there's a
slightly different charging regime but
um in essence the the costs for the
deposits don't don't go up so
um yes very much a status quo budget for
the next two to three years and happy to
take any questions
thanks man any questions of that
all right thank you matt thanks for all
your work and your
and your team's work in that area
appreciate it
so we're up to um building units
so that's page 535.
lauren okay um good afternoon councilman
um like matt this is pretty much a
best guest of what we think the future
is going to hold the next year
and as we found out in december all of
our guesses
weren't particularly good to be fair
when we ended up with something in the
order of two months worth of work
turning up in three weeks
so that has its own challenges which
we're currently working through
but nonetheless looking at this longer
term issue that
one that i dare say has exercised a bit
of interest is the change in fees
for the heating units and i got a note
there from a counsellor to say would we
consider
splitting this over a couple of years i
have no problem with that at all
so just need a bit of a steer on that
for what the councillors would like
as far as the heating units go so what
is the increase in that
well it goes from 390 to about 400
i mean you're seeing my glasses 480
dollars which is quite a jump
but it really is a bit of an average of
what we've sort of spent on
um heating units they become a you know
we're not a loss leader we just end up
doing the work for a lot less than it
costs us to be fair
yeah is there any objection to spreading
that over a couple of years
so these are steer okay thank you very
much that's fine
um apart from that the budget there are
a couple of line items and the expenses
that have
uh jumped and they jump off the page at
you and one being the
changes to the software for go get or
100 increase
this is what happens when omar and pa
own a business and it gets taken over by
a corporate
and everything's up for grabs so it's um
double the price basically for that and
if we want to use the system that's the
cost
so we've just just left that in the
system
we've got a wee bit of additional costs
or we've actually clawed back
at what it cost to do with our training
for regulation 18 so we need to have
people with technical qualifications
and that's where that extra sort of 27
000 case comes from
if we go down to another line item which
would be
the internal transfers uh costs for it
supports gone up by 48 000
but apart from that is pretty much
business as usual really
does anyone have any questions
um thank you this this looks really good
um i notice in the
for the budgeting purposes the
the budget increases each year and the
main budget is based on building
or rates increases of of
dwellings and things at 480 average per
year
and yeah we we've had a bit of a slow
down but we've exceeded that this year
but
i see in 22 23 year consent numbers will
rise to 600 to 640 per annument
in them and given that silver stream and
there's another retirement village
about to be started ravenswood and
rangiora
east um am i right
in thinking that the income
budgets based on dwellings that are
built bills in the region over the next
10 years are going to be well
underestimated
it may well prove to be true but we have
to start with something so we've gone on
a bit of a whatever
to some extent as a conversation we've
had with some of the developers to sit
there and go
what's the timing of these turning up
and you've got a subdivision down in
raven's woods for a hundred and
something sections that sounds like a
lot
but it's not really in the sense of we
and easily uh that's probably
you know three months worth of work uh
but look at the land development that's
going on
some of the timing around that is really
our issue and we know that
um some of the stuff that's going on
with the retirement complexes
i do they will have an influence on us
but just when they turn up it's actually
quite hard to predict
i think jim's about to say something as
well yeah we
warren's absolutely right for for our
for our long-term plan
we base our uh growth
in number of households based on stats
projections and we picked that middle
high variant and it's gonna
and and we anticipate by the in ten
years we get to 78 000 as a population
in terms of our growth apart from
perhaps the first year or so
we straight line that as jeff indicated
yesterday that's 4
800 new households over the 10 years
it always we've always been a bit above
that
um but to make our assumptions in our
budget line up we need to show that
we've used consistent assumptions if we
said
well we've got 4 800 household growth
over the 10 years
but we then go and plan for a building
unit to have say
600 lots a year that's 7 200 and
somebody comes along and says well hold
on which
that doesn't reconcile now new lots
created and new house bills
don't necessarily correlate 100 so there
is a bit of
estimation around the edges and warren
uses his best guess based on what he
knows off the market but
overall we try and flatten it so it
doesn't look
too out of line but it'll the reality is
it'll be what it is
if you if sell one if somebody asked
would seldwin still be doing 800
households a year
this many years on from their peak where
people
know we don't have the land though at
the moment to continue to drive and
that's our biggest factor that
we're all conscious of so that that is
an issue but
the good thing with the building unit is
warren has arrangements in place
positive and negative to manage the
volume so
the use of consultants contractors is
able to scale up and down to
try and live within acceptable time
frames and
cost pressures so it's our best guess
today and all we know is that it'll be
wrong
but it won't be too far wrong
all right any any other questions of one
oh
council williams
um at the moment it's only sitting
around about 12 or 13 days
but that's statuary days not calendar
days on my head
and it's been on a um saturday stop over
christmas
so even though people might be counting
the surgery clock is not moving but it
has started again but
to sort of um rather than allow our
customers to wonder and scratch the head
that
nothing's happening whether on monday
there'll be a series of emails going out
weekly to customers to give them a heads
up when we estimate
will be picking up their job to start
because it's likely we'll end up with a
percentage of jobs that will go over 20
working days
probably the first time we've been in
this position for 10 years to be fair
and it takes a while to ramp up you end
up with sort of two and a half three
months worth of work turning up and
three weeks it takes a while to scratch
your head and work out where you're
gonna get some capacity from
uh we're getting there but it's gonna
take us a few weeks to get
the dick chairs all sorted but we'll get
we'll get it sorted
right okay
any further questions don't think
there's any amendments proposed sort of
thanks warren
appreciate it appreciate you and the
team's work
all right so we've now got uh why don't
we deal with
um environmental services and
civil defense and then we might have a
breakdown break
okay so environmental
environmental health environmental
services this budget
thanks warren this budget was prepared
by nick and tracy who are both no longer
with us so
between matt myself we'll try and answer
any questions again
essentially a status quo budget there's
a there's a suggestion
dollar nudge in dog registration
fees which is probably i think
just at the margins to keep to
just to keep nudging that along which
isn't too bad there's a
there is parking uh in town
centres you know there's a little more
work being done
on enforcement in one of the capital
budgets you'll see
an outlier for portable
electronic parking devices it's a
placeholder
sitting out half a dozen years to say
probably electronic technology to
support
town centre parking will be needed and
there's still some further work to be
done around that
the technology i understand is changing
reasonably quickly in that space
as to how best to deliver that those
type of services so
it's an acknowledgement that things will
change there and we probably should and
it goes with the rest of the town centre
parking strategy work
as to what's the best mix of solutions
to help manage parking demand
and parking availability there are there
is a
ongoing need for us to look at the after
hours contract and how effective we are
delivering that and i know
uh tracy tierney when she arrives one of
the things that she will be thinking
about is the
overall service provision and it's fair
to say
um it creaks and groans uh regularly
and uh there whether there are better
arrangements in place we know that that
is an
issue that whether that translates to a
demand probably there is a point in time
i think around
particularly animal control where we may
have to think in
alternate service delivery arrangements
because
the after our service i
probably is not keeping pace with the
expectations of our community or our
council in that space so
we know that that's an issue and we know
that
and i've a great deal of confidence in
tracy keaney's capability
and to have a look at that and work
with others who utilize after our
services to
review that happy to take any questions
any questions tell us about it and i'll
come to you tonight
thank you for that explanation jim i got
some answers back from my questions but
i'm not quite sure who did them so
neither am i probably was that you met
yes combination of myself
okay cool um i'm just a bit concerned
that we've we've had a change of
personnel in the animal control area and
it's meant that some of the budgets have
dropped
because we've had someone retire but the
service is still remaining the same
why wouldn't you keep the budgets at the
same level
rather than dropping them i'm just
concerned we won't have enough personnel
in that area
um in my in my view we're actually well
resourced
for the that staff there is a vacancy
yeah that there is a structural review
that tracy tierney will need to look at
as well
with chris goldsmith's retirement which
is what you're referring to
right now we went from three offices
we went from one officer to two offices
to three offices
and we went to four offices and the
expectation that
chris was retiring and we're now at
three
and there's probably a workload of
somewhere between three three and a half
so there's a
there's a supervisor potential role that
has
broader than animal control
responsibilities
in it but it's again that's another
matter for tracy tierney to look at so
um i i think there is
well matt i'd be interested in your take
on that as well but i think there's
plenty of
i think there's enough resources
dropping those budgets okay
i get yes so that's essentially the
answer i was going to give as well as
excellent my second question was on
parking
you mentioned the placeholder budget for
electronics but
we were kind of promised that perhaps a
bit earlier
in terms of rang euro and trying to
remove the all-day parkas
is there any other options such as
introducing a person who would be
more full-time and should we put a
placeholder budget
and for trying to improve um enforcement
in the rain eurotown centre
do you have a view on that map even if
it's three four years out but just just
to have it in the actual long-term plan
because we're still getting a lot of
complaints about all-day parking around
maritime
i get a lot of complaints about their
enforcer engineering wow
i think i have to say sorry man so it
shows that they're doing it
so i think the similar to the the dog
budget
um there is capacity there in doing and
i think some of it comes down to the
structure of how we
how we deliver that service um and
um working through that so i don't
necessarily think that there's a
extra budget provision that is needed
but there's certainly a sort of an
overall view as to how we how we provide
that service and
and and you know what resource we use as
well okay
i accept that that's you know i think we
should be looking at that and i
my suggestion is uh dpnr
once tracy settled and start to have a
conversation about what other
level of services that we're seeking
what's her take on it
and then i i would say i would say that
over the course of the next year you
might see yourself
having a strategy that you want to
reflect on
sounds good any further questions so did
you
question council members
it's been a long day yeah um
parking enforcement fines i've noticed
we don't even select even
fifty percent of them why is that
because
we don't take court action or no because
my understanding is and i'm looking
almost at jeff as well as
matt but um when when when a
when a fine you know when we issue a
parking fine and it remains unfo
un uh collected it's then referred to
the court
is that that's my understanding
yes and my observation having said and
the role overseeing
some of that over the last week as we
actually do um we are quite stringent on
on the ones that we
that we waive so but once it gets into
the court
system outside of outside of us
so just a supplementary
yeah i just wondering why we just can't
go to a depletion agency rather than
straight to report on that
like a civil because it i don't think
you can take a
and i'm looking at robbie almost i'm not
sure you take a fine to
a debt collector i think it has to
um when i hit my garage
that's a debt collector and we use debt
collectors for other services
because it's a fine it's a levied fine
it's a fine that's imposed under
legislation and as
council of brian said the the if if
somebody fails to pay that
you have the opportunity to contest that
and the contest
place for that is in court they still
have that
ability to contest if you go through a
call for example a motor vehicle thing
here and that that
updates i think the difference is the
legislation provides for the court
process
rather than the rather than the you know
the questions
we've got to
and one more question what would be
looking at the after he asked for
dogs a dog gets impounded people can't
get him out until monday apparently
yeah um so the answer is yes we will
look at that so there was a case
recently and i think that one um
had some other circumstances and context
around it but certainly that's one of
the things that we will look at
operationally is
with our duty amos can they can they go
down and organize for that because they
will be down there doing things for the
dogs so
i mean i just wonder that uncollected
fines whether part of that is when
we let people off the fines where
there's a care
a percentage of that that's carried
forward so for instance you get
um fine for no no warrant but in 28 days
if you get one we generally
take the fine back is that is that part
of that
unpaid fight there would always be an
element of that gary yeah yes
yes would that be the element of it
that'll be an element of it so that
doesn't automatically happen as well so
someone
even though if they say they pay the
fine they still need to apply
to have the information removed so
um
[Music]
and if you hadn't caught up matters matt
is our new
lead civil defense controller so when
the balloon is on the way up or
gone off the alarm's gone off matters
the first
is now follows nick's previous role as
lead controller so
we remain in good steady hands now
okay this this budget is actually asking
for
uh a little more than just a status quo
um if brennan was here and i um
i'm sure he wouldn't mind me saying he
he would have actually
liked to bid for even more than this and
we've
uh we've sort of paired him back in his
budget
third probably the thing he would like
most
is actually another civil defense
officer
and the capacity of the team to do
what is coming and what needs to be done
in both a readiness preparedness and
response level then
there is no shortage of work to keep
people busy now
we disappointed brennan
in our review and said look and given
the budget constraints we're facing
we didn't see that as something we could
support to council but of course as the
officer concerned he's
certainly entitled to bring his view to
your table
for your consideration so um
that's it's there are a couple of other
items in the budget which are
of lesser amounts which you know we
certainly do support as a management
team
around education and awareness a couple
of
items there um af8
and the like so happy to take any
questions
and chris is here thanks chris to deal
with the tricky ones
um did you want to anyway
[Music]
jim just just around your commentary on
another fte
um first is it relevant but second
uh what's the ftes of other councils of
similar size
and are we doing ourselves this favor
point and i mean i said
i'm not blocking what you've done as
management i just you know what are
other
where are other councils what they have
to use on and and look there is a
there is a contextual element to this as
well and that there is
a regional review
likely to that is sort of kicking off to
talk about
what's the best way for civil defense
delivery to occur should it be regional
regional with local bases or
retention of the status quo and there's
a number of different operating models
around the country and
and one of the reasons for that review
is to provide
greater capability to the region
for civil defense i would say
relative to other councils we are we're
not the
best dressed but we're far from the
worst race so
um i think selwyn has three offices
from memory chris two and a half two and
a half
uh there are others who are you know i
think
failing to discharge their
responsibilities
and they have a part-time
civil defense officer who's also a
forestry officer who's also a dog
chaser and everything else in the
business as well enough
really are failing to meet the
responsibilities and so
a lot of the regional effort i think if
you asked neville riley
you know is he concerned about the
capability and capacity of
waimakariri while he would never say no
to more
i think he would be pointing his finger
elsewhere first
most would have won as
the of our mid-size council would be
what somewhere between one and
two the rurals small rurals
just about all of them are less than one
fte
quick question um this af8 are we going
to
bring that back again for
another viewing elsewhere
it was very successful um certainly
that's
what brennan's intention is is um to
push out an um presentation
to the whole district and that's part of
the reason for the extra person as well
um but not just looking at the parents
but also
um looking at schools and that sort of
stuff as well so getting in
at the ground level um but yeah
so he's certainly um looking at that
along with the tsunami risk
with the change in modelling that's come
out just recently
okay any other questions
the current officers haven't got the
skill set to do education in this in the
secondary schools
which is going to be a growing concer
growing need um
if we thought about um secondly sam
as a youth officer in that role would
that be a possibility
i certainly couldn't answer that um but
more broadly we have been thinking about
how do we deliver
education services across the whole
gambit of our council activity
solid and hazardous waste
some of our other education activities
such as drainage and waterways
we are thinking about how how we could
better deliver those in
those programs and i think the
readiness and preparedness
activities of civil defence certainly
sit within that but
i would agree with brennan that it's a
it's a different set of skills to those
the technical capability obviously rests
in the team but it's a different you
know the actual teaching
and delivery skills are a different
skill set so i would acknowledge that
and further support
would be a good thing but your um
chris you're working in with sam at the
moment with the cadets and
the other person works with quite lumber
actually tears are collaborating
yeah so we we uh we deal with the
basically the high school
12 to eight 18 year olds um not not too
much of an issue here it's the
the primary schools is where the the big
issue is
dealing with kids of that age um is
mostly probably where brenda and i come
from military backgrounds
so if you want to produce a lot of
soldiers we could do that for you
with those kids but um yeah
yeah councilman do you have a question
um
going from 6 000 to 10 000 for community
engagement on afa
tsunami and community integration
including
translating things into tedeo um
jim that that's just not going to do
anything
um why wouldn't we if we're serious
about this why wouldn't we look at
increasing that a little bit more
um because we've got some budget
challenges as a council and we asked
everybody to
uh to only put forward bids which were
essential and
in the baseline and everything else was
subject to your consideration
so we have uh
we've been doing that right across the
[Music]
council so there are lots of bids that
didn't get to you that
you know we've had to manage one way or
another
any other questions cuts for redmond
in a minute i'll just yeah yeah jim
one of the other things that springs to
mind is we have um
people in our pools who deliver
education
quite well to younger students if we are
we looking at
whether there's some cross synergies
there that could be uh
could be utilized is that something
we've done
doesn't matter whether you have an
answer to that really to be honest it's
just
yeah look it's uh they're another
they're another delivery agent same with
our libraries they deliver a lot of
services to youth as well so um
yeah thank you okay
this is where the questions become
points or
amendments i was just going to comment
down
on page 566 for example the warning
system
warning siren system maintenance
has gone from 7 000 to 17 000
and i did ask about that and the reason
for that is in the old days that
somebody an electrician or someone would
climb up a ladder and
do his fit now you've got to have uh
scissors to get up to that height
and tuning so the cost
just runs away so that's just the
reality of
health and safety but i'd also like just
like to say that i think we're very
fortunate to have chris and brennan
here they're both very passionate about
what they do
and when i first came upon civil defence
many years ago there was half a person
probably less actually and i don't know
how competent he was but
he carried the title so we complied with
the legislation i suppose so i think we
are very lucky
and that the gap that's been identified
is primary school education
and i did talk to brennan um and
knuckle neck about you know
some way that we could deliver that um
it's we bit like
echo educate do it in a rubbish sense
we want to do this find somebody
passionate
to do it about civil defence um
and if i make the analogy of the
umbrella
civil defence really we've got it
we don't probably give it a lot of
importance until we actually need it
and then it becomes very vital and
essential so it's like having an
umbrella it's not much first until it
rains
but you need to have one
so i think we've got a very good civil
defense team and thank you to chris
and brennan and matt and we're
positioned
i just decided to just to add and
comment
commentary that the fantastic civil
defence team and chris
uh and brennan both do an outstanding
job um and
and if it wasn't for chris's instigation
we wouldn't have the cadet program the
first in the country
i'm really proud of that it's a really
fantastic
program being along to the awards and
just seeing how those young people have
developed
in this last 12 months so it's really
exceptional
in terms of a program that's education
focused i wonder
if it might be worth us exploring
i'm happy to open i come really well
with the director of education whether
it's with a conversation with
coraline child and also talking with
tessa and the team around any
discretionary funding that may
exist to start that to pilot it see how
that goes in terms of getting a resource
and then our council could look at um
perhaps
a little further down the track adding
additional resources to support you i i
realize it's a difficult time and
budgetary-wise we've we've asked
everyone else to
just take a bit of a pull um so it's
probably just something just not right
at the moment that's not to say
um that it won't it's not something
you're adding back down the track but i
think there's some other
sources that we could look at that could
um potentially
fund and pilot that work but
just chris team thanks we really
appreciate what you do and i i think we
are
i listen to our other councils some of
the forums i met
we are exceptionally well served here uh
and i i don't like that to what council
redmond says actually
i think you know when i when we look at
several defence events
and and even the uh pines beach um
thanks for keeping us in the loop
keeping us informed chris
and both brennan i was getting text
messages through so
i do appreciate the communication that
comes through to us because it keeps us
in the link and you're down there
and active and involved as our nz
12 and other groups that are associated
so things for that
kirsten just very quick comment i mean
if af8 happened tomorrow
we have to survive at least three days
by ourselves
so it's asking can our each of our
communities do it
i actually think they probably can
because of the huge volunteer network
throughout the district and that's it
partly due to the collaboration that's
been developed by brennan chris
across all the emergency agencies and
the community team through all the
social services as well so
and they work together really really
brilliantly so i think we have got a
safety net
but i do think that education of our
population as to what they do
would help a great deal and i think it's
something that we have to look at
and with the with primary school i'm
just yeah i've got that concern about
duplication because i know that my kids
would come home and teach me stuff
so they obviously get something in the
curriculum so it would be really good to
see
whether we can complement that and show
them what the local stuff is as well as
the national stuff so
the kids seem to often know a lot more
than the adults do
so i think actually the biggest place we
need to educate are
those who think it's not going to happen
to them
okay hear the comments quickly on
the that particular item i mean i can
remember
we did cross-education with the with the
poor staff
and coast guard and i remember standing
in a room with uh
with children who were just just about
to leave to go to high school
we asked them a couple of questions and
um
the kid that was there was i don't know
how old are they when they go to high
school
something like that eleven twelve
something like i don't know i'm out of
step with that
whatever age they are and uh
this young fella answered the question i
said to him how did you know that
he said because you told me when you
came and talked to us at primary school
now i assume that's what you're looking
for to make sure
that that happens but i really do push
the cross agencies that we have here to
deliver the message that you have we're
already in the education
educating on swim we're already coast
guards are doing their bit on there but
you guys are doing your bit it's
actually about that collaboration with
tessa's team to make sure they can make
their educations
happen the biggest thing you have to do
is actually get the buy-in from the
education sector and that is the hardest
bit
okay yes
just um trying to get um people to uh
recognise that
that uh there are issues and they need
to be they need to be well informed on
them
and that was claimed very clearly about
the
younger parent generation that they just
don't want to know
about that and they just seem to think
that's all scaremongering and that
they're just not
they weren't interested in even coming
along to their own eight there are a lot
of older people there
but that generation um
under 30s they just weren't even
interested
and that is really sad because it's it's
something that um
you know they need to be aware of for
their children's
okay budget's done thank you
thanks team thanks for coming along
thanks matt
i appreciate all the work you're doing
stepping up in the interim as well and
and also as our and our new role as
controller so
it's great to have you there all right
so we've got
uh left for mike uh there's information
technology support we've got property
housing and elding elderly
district management and organisational
hr
development so that lasts for if we can
break now
we come back at 10 past four that will
give you a stretch time for a cup of
coffee and
we're in the home street we're in the
home stretch
all right okay